We are using CUDA to run a blurring kernel on a gray scale image
where each pixel is a 32-bit single precision floating point number.
Let's consider that the kernel is a 5 by 5 kernel, and we're not going to worry about where it's stored.
Then our operation will be 25 multiplies and 24 adds to compute each pixel output.
Naturally, we want to use shared memory to store the image so that
we save memory bandwidth by reading each pixel as few times as possible.
Our code will look something like this.
You can choose how to launch this kernel in terms of threads per block configuration.
You have 2 choices, 1024 by 1 or 32 by 32. Both choices will feature 1,024 threads per block.
So the first question is, which 1 of these 2 configurations
will require less global memory bandwidth?
Please choose here.
And the second question is, how much less was the ratio
of global memory bandwidth between the kernel that uses more memory bandwidth and the kernel with less?
In your calculation, please ignore the bandwidth required for the blurKernel
and the bandwidth required for right back of v new, and please enter your answer here.